[Music]
here's some BuzzFeed lists I saw
recently that just didn't have a look at
this 1:27 potatoes that look like gérard
Depardieu
okay maybe but we're island-y and which
one is which look at this 117 White
Walkers who identify as black look at
this eight singers who look like they
have bad breath
that's Tom tuna-salad Ron say hey I am
nine rear Admirals who still giggle at
their title look at this twenty two frat
boys who mistook salt for cocaine
check this out twelve Footwear options
that will flatter your cankles eleven
Birds who went out of their way to [ __ ]
on you look at that bird didn't even
have to go what a jerk look at this one
13 babies who wonder what's the point 11
belts that are working overtime and I
think so
22 family portraits taken right before
the divorce
look at them everybody knows look at
this one seven brain donors who now have
second thoughts
and finally nine gargoyles who suffer
from erectile dysfunction
[Applause]
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]